if some of you guys were afraid about
kovid look how he injects the fear of
Cyber attack and other things in his
method of marketing so press play
insufficient attention
the frightening scenario of a
comprehensive Cyber attack which would
bring to a complete hold
power supply
Transportation Hospital services our
society as a whole
90 crisis would be seen in this respect
as a small disturbance in comparison to
a major Cyber attack
I I I don't understand can I can I ask
you yeah sure it's not my show okay so I
would be respectful can you put up the
Apple 1984 ad identical it's the same
music it's like it's like just identity
it's the first thing I thought about it
is the first thing I thought about it
straight up is like you wouldn't that's
the face don't play it just show the
face that looks like this is gonna use
the audio guy who is like that's Cloud
Schwab on the screen yeah tell me that
is that the exact same way think about
that German literally you think about
Adolf you think about 1984 it's the
message how is he convincing people like
Hey Joe Biden to say let me announce my
candidacy campaign to be built back
better which he's the build back better
guys so why are people buying into this
guy why is he have so much influence
over people so the answer comes down to
money okay actually so it comes down to
money but he doesn't have money he
doesn't have money no no no it's not
even it's not even this man I mean
that's I I gotta gotta tell you
something I was asked by The Wall Street
Journal to review a book that he wrote
what in like early 2020 or 2021 right a
couple years ago and through reading
that book I get the sense that he's just
her individual who has had this passion
for 50 years and in his own heart is
just one man who has his views their
views that I deeply disagree with but he
happens to have exercised influence
because everyone else with money 360
Degrees surrounding him had a use for
that okay Larry Fink is on the board of
the world economic Forum of Davos Cloud
Schwab done that money or not you know
seriously large-scale way Larry think
controls 20 controls eight to ten
trillion dollars under the purview of
one man that's probably the largest was
he was Larry being who you're talking a
black rock lyric I think yeah I mean
that that is
probably the largest aggregation of
capital under one man's Authority no
question in human history more than the
Dutch East India Company okay and he's
in the border the world economic form of
Dabba so what does this accomplish it is
a front
that is what this is the front and you
know what these things always come in
three letter acronyms right e-s-g-d-e-i
SRI socially responsible investing CSR
my favorite three-letter acronym is the
CCP you look at Klaus Schwab Heap
elevates the CCP he talks about the
Chinese model of dealing with covid-19
not in a way not to do it but in the way
to do it right so so here's the way this
game works okay the black rocks of the
world
apply constraints to the West emissions
caps what kinds of energy you can and
cannot use what kinds of diversity you
must have they apply that to the West
without applying those same constraints
in places like China I'll give you a
very specific example okay they're
pressuring companies like Exxon to adopt
scope 3 emissions caps
that causes companies like Exxon to drop
oil projects now a couple years ago
there's an oil project in the Sichuan
province of China Chevron drops it
you might wonder hey maybe this is part
of the fight against global climate
change maybe that project isn't
proceeding you'd be wrong that same
project is proceeding just under new
ownership who's the new ownership it is
Petro China
now you take a look at who's one of the
larger shareholders of petrochina
it is none other than BlackRock the same
party who's pressuring firms
and Chevron yeah so so the interesting
thing here is that
taketh from the left hand and give it to
the right that's last time I checked
we're supposed to be fighting global
climate change I'm just saying a
three-card Monty going on follow the
money and in the one way or another
forum is this is this front that gives
this that sort of creates this veneer
of legitimacy when in fact because it's
a non-profit Global Allegiance and
organization conceived by this elderly
Swiss gentleman Klaus Schwab when in
fact it is just a vehicle for advancing
an agenda that impedes the objectives of
the West without laying a finger on
China or the Chinese economy and so the
CCP is the most relevant three-letter
acronym looking by disease I'll give you
another little mystery here
why is it part of the global ESG agenda
to be hostile towards nuclear energy so
the first Paradox is why do they shift
production to China and they're okay
with it oh and by the way if any climate
activists listening to this I mean just
to give you a fact to think about
tonight when you go to bed methane
leakage a unit of methane is 80 times
worse for global warming than carbon
dioxide okay people talk about carbon
emissions well if you don't actually
have a database debate you can't just
talk about carbon you have to talk about
the difference between carbon dioxide
methane and other forms of carbon turns
out methane leakage is 80 times worse
for global warming than carbon dioxide
guess where methane leakage is worse in
places like Russia and China so
when you shift production from the U.S
to other parts of the world it's not
just that it's net neutral with woke
washing it's worse than that because
you're actually contributing to more
methane leakage into the atmosphere than
you were even in the U.S you've done
even more harm on your own terms even if
you subscribe to this crazy religious
zealotry
even if you subscribe to that you have
failed on your own terms so that's the
first mystery now I'll give you a second
mystery and then you see the conclusion
the second mystery is why are they
hostile to nuclear energy because you
would think if you were opposed to all
this carbon emission stuff
you would be embracing the greatest form
of carbon-free
large-scale reliable energy production
known to mankind that is nuclear energy
and yet
ESG funds like vanguard's ESG fund
systematically by rule exclude nuclear
energy
now scratch your head for a second and
ask what's going on there
the answer is this whole agenda the
anti-nuclear disposition included
is really not about climate change at
all
it is about making the West apologize
for its sins of the past to achieve a
paradigm of global Equity the problem
with nuclear energy
is not that it is not good enough
it is that it is too good at solving the
supposed energy crisis or clean energy
crisis which means you lose the E the
environmental prong is ESG as a trojan
horse for the S the social agenda and
that's really what's going on here is
the whole climatism and the world
economic Forum this is a each of these
is just a front it's a trojan horse it's
a vehicle
for advancing an equity driven agenda
that the citizenry of most democracies
in the west including the United States
would have never tolerated
if you didn't disguise it in the
religious veneer of covetism or
climatism or whatever other secular
religion ends up being the vehicle for
advancing that that is what's going on
here so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]